revient maintenant sur ce projet de loi
sont les peines de prison à vie sans
possibilité de libération conditionnelle
que stephen rapp et s'est engagé à faire
revivre si les conservateurs sont
reportés au pouvoir
j'accueille l'avocat criminaliste walid
hijazi suis jazzy bonsoir alors si vous
le rappeur revient à la charge veut
qu'une peine sans possibilité ration
conditionnelle soit vraiment une peine
sans possibilité de libération
conditionnelle
pourquoi est-ce que c'est nécessaire
quel problème ça viendrait régler c'est
une bonne question je ne vois pas le
problème que ça viendrait régler quand
on dit qu'une personne est libéré après
25 ans ce n'est pas un automatisme
prenant elle doit le mériter il ya un
organisme de la commission nationale des
libérations conditionnelles qui évalue
la possibilité de pouvoir l'a libéré et
si tant est qu'elle soit libérée qu'elle
est en liberté
sa peine de prison continuer dans la
collectivité elle va continuer d'être
soumise à des conditions sévères jusqu'à
la fin de ses jours
alors il ne faut pas penser que c'est un
automatisme d'une part et par ailleurs
il ya d'autres outils aux quatre
criminels pour neutraliser les criminels
qu'on considère réellement irrécupérable
alors j'imagine que certains peuvent
avoir des craintes que des criminels
très dangereux on peut penser à paul
bernardo bourse est un roc oman iota se
retrouvent en liberté c'est ça qu'on
sous-entend vous encore une fois la
libération conditionnelle doit se
mériter et avant avant de se rendre de
25 ans plus tard au moment d'une
libération au moment de la détermination
de la peine si on estime qu'un individu
est totalement irrécupérable à cause du
caractère répété de ces crimes ses
antécédents judiciaires ou sa nature
particulièrement brutale le code
criminel permet au juge de le déclarer
ou bien délinquant dangereux ou
délinquant à contrôler de façon à garder
un certain contrôle sur cette
personne-là possiblement l'a gardé
détenu jusqu'à là juste pour une période
indéterminée
allant jusqu'à la fin de ses jours alors
je ne vois pas le besoin de réformer le
système ici bon est ce que on peut se
demander est ce que ça peut créer des
changements de comportement par exemple
pour des détenus qui saurait qui nous
qui sont en prison jusqu'à la fin de
leurs jours est-ce que des risques quand
on sort du cadre du droit mais cela le
groupe globo
s'en soucier en fait une dimension
juridique de total et la réhabilitation
ici on vient éliminer l'aspect
réhabilitation de toute peine à et qui
privé par lequel criminelle
ici un individu qui est déjà quelqu'un
de dangereux et dont on enlève la
possibilité de libérer un jour de plus
aucun espoir de retrouver la liberté
alors je ne voudrais pas être un
codétenu où un employé de cet
établissement carcéral aussi un individu
ne plus aucun espoir de sortir un jour
s'il a tué une ou deux personnes
qu'est-ce qu'il lui prive de tuer
d'autres personnes en prison s'il ne
sera jamais libéré de toute façon la
réhabilitation fait partie de notre
siège
ça fait partie de la philosophie
pénologie canadienne et c'est également
énoncé expressément au code criminel
une peine plusieurs bus plus en
vocations punir dissuader servir
d'exemple elle vise également la
réhabilitation ici on vient on vit
éliminé l'aspect réhabilitation d'une
peine tout ce que ça passera le test la
charte c'est adopter on peut très
certainement prévoir une bataille au
niveau concerné la charte prévoit
interdit la peine qu'on dit cruel et
inusité on abolit la peine de mort en
1976 ce genre de mesure quant à moi on
vient tuer l'âme de la personne vient
ramener un peu là la peine de mort par
la porte d'en arrière
je ne le vois pas autrement
on tue tout espoir de redevenir un actif
pour la société je suis d'avis merci
beaucoup appris